so today we're going to talk about how
to rid kidney stones with lemons okay
beginning a lot of requests from people
that want to know what am I going to do
it with my kidney stone reserve some
remedies and so I'm gonna just create
this one video to summarize the latest
information most of the kidney stones
that develop are calcium oxalate stones
fifty-nine percent okay ten percent are
calcium phosphate stones 17% are uric
acid stones okay so we're gonna be
focusing on the oxalates right now so
what happens when the ox lets combine
with the calcium in the kidney they can
form these razor-sharp little crystals
that not only irritate your kidney but
they can irritate your joints and other
tissues as well
what causes kidney stones now there are
several things that increase the risk of
getting a kidney stone decrease your in
volume not consuming enough fluids okay
you're dehydrated increase oxalates in
the body ox let's come from the food and
your body makes ox let's okay part of
the defense mechanism is to create these
oxalates which inhibit the consumption
of that plant so it's a kind of a
survival mechanism when we increase the
consumption of certain foods with
oxalates it can start building up and
creating problems so you'd want to make
sure that your oxalates in your diet
don't exceed 50 milligrams per day an
average person consumes about 200 or
more milligrams what it is I created
this food chart from high to low based
on one cup okay and I also have the
spices in here and at the top the list
you know it has the most oxalates
parsley then we have rhubarb spinach
radish garlic mixed nuts rice bran
peanuts beets so anyway if you want this
list I put a link down below you can
check this out you can consume a little
bit of calcium citrate with the meal to
minimize the dietary oxalates not a lot
just a little bit maybe one tablet or
consume some goat or sheep cheese
because the calcium will combine
with the oxalate in the digestive system
and go through the body and not be
absorbed as much into the blood and
through the kidney okay so this is just
a little tip right here so it increases
the risk for getting a kidney stone is
decrease your in volume high oxalates in
the body too acidic your your urine is a
little too acidic increase blood calcium
and low sit rates citrate is a compound
that can either come from your body your
body can make it from certain metabolic
pathways or it can come from foods
okay certain foods when you have low sit
rates your risk of kidney stones go up
significantly now if you look up the
definition of low sit rates through the
body there's two definitions okay it's
this total excretion of less than 320
milligrams
another definition said less than 500
milligrams I don't know which one it is
but it's somewhere probably in the
middle so you're just not producing or
getting enough citrates and these
oxalate stones are forming so sit rates
do three things and they inhibit the
formation of stones they help dissolve
stones and they also inhibit the
stickiness of the calcium oxalate to the
kidney tissue itself allowing the the
stone to go through the body without
sticking okay so now here is the perfect
remedy for kidney stones lemon juice
okay why because lemon juice has the
highest concentrate of saturates out of
any food it also helps to alkalize the
body even though lemons are have citric
acid they turn alkaline after their burn
in the body okay now can you use lime
absolutely you can work you can use
lemon or lime doesn't make a difference
and lemons are low calcium and they have
very low amounts of fructose because
fructose can also increase the risk of
getting kidney stones and especially
uric acid stones now why can't we use
cranberry juice
I mean you've probably heard that
cranberry juice is good for the kidney
well cranberry juice is good might be
good for the kidney but it's not
necessarily good to dissolve stones okay
can't we use grapefruit because that has
that right well grapefruit does have
citric acid not as much as lemon it does
help dissolve calcium oxalate stones but
lemon dissolves the calcium oxalate
stones and the calcium phosphate stones
and it also can help decrease uric acid
stones okay so that that's why we use
lemon or okay so here's what you gonna
do in the morning you're gonna drink one
cup of lemon juice okay don't add any
water just drink it straight you can
drink it with a straw or just drink it
down and then you can chase it down with
a little water to clean out the teeth
now also take one cup of lemon juice and
mix it with ten cups of water and you're
gonna be using that to drink through the
day what you're trying to do is keep
your sit rates very very high in the
body so we don't form any stones and so
we start dissolving stones and by the
way guys any remedies that I recommend
check with your doctor first if you're
on some type of medical program work
with your doctor to see if you can do it
and all my recommendations are not meant
to replace your medical care or cure you
of any diseases okay so that's my
disclaimer on that a couple questions
are gonna come up can I use lemon juice
from a jar or fresh lemons both of those
options will work the fresh lemon gives
some extra benefit of more vitamin C and
usually when you have a kidney stone you
have inflammation so that vitamin C is
helpful now as far as the topic about
them and see there's some conflicting
data on vitamin C with kidney stones
there's some studies that will say that
taking vitamin C will increase your risk
of getting stones others will say it'll
decrease it but these studies were done
on synthetic vitamin C not on the
vitamin C from lemons or not on the
vitamin C from foods so you don't really
have to worry about that worsening
thinks it's just gonna help things a
little bit if you can do actual lemons
but it's a little more expensive so I
recommend either organic lemon juice I
mean the ideal lemon juice would be the
volcano lemon juice is from Italy they
have the best but you can use any lemon
juice all right and one last point when
you're drinking this lemon water through
the day use a straw that works better
than exposing it to your teeth anyway so
I hope this is helpful and again if you
want to download this chart I put a link
down below alright guys thanks for
watching so if you're enjoying this
content go ahead and share it with
someone that could really benefit from
it